bonsoir à tous la compagnie des tisseurs
de son jeu vous invite à une
saint-valentin plaine de jeux et de
mystère c'est diviser les enquêteurs
pour ne pas vous faire démasquer
chacun tient son rôle pour cette murder
party thématiques à l'espace decaux
villes de voisins-le-bretonneux le 17
février pour être plus spectateur la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux vous propose de passer la soirée
avec valentina del pearls l'effeuilleuse
burlesque promet un show plein de plumes
et paillettes saupoudré d'humour déjanté
si vous voulez entrer dans la danse et
développer votre sensualité pour de
nouvelles conquêtes penser à la bachata
cette danse originaire de république
dominicaine est considérée comme la plus
romantique des danses latines et
l'association mambo la danse de saint
germain en laye vous propose des stages
intensifs pour débutants une fois par
mois
le prochain aura lieu le 31 mars idéal
pour cet amour de printemps retrouver
l'amour pour soi
la saint valentin est l'occasion rêvée
pour réaliser cette introspection et
réfléchir à ses relations passées
évitez les schémas répétitifs de
dépendance affective car pour trouver un
amour st il faut d'abord s'aimer soi
même
ce sera un moment pour faire un petit
bilan de sa vie amoureuse de définir ce
qu'on veut ce qu'on ne veut pas au sein
de cette relation un moment pour ouvrir
son coeur on pourra les
rechercher quels ont été les expériences
douloureuses les guérir grâce à un
travail en sophrologie avec donc un
travail sur l'inconscient qui va
permettre de libérer ses mémoires
enfin pour les fraîchement séparée qui
n'ont pas encore dépassé le stade de la
rancoeur
le centre de conservation pour animaux
hemsley au royaume uni vous propose de
baptiser un cafard avec le nom de votre
ex pour 2 euros vous offrez ce patronyme
briscard à l'une de ses très charmant
petites bêtes et vous aider aux
différents projets du zoo alors aux
lakers on y croit l'année prochaine vous
ne serez plus seul